all right so first of all um i'm really
happy to be talking to you here today
and the title of the talk
speculation and resonation
i'm going to go ahead and explain to you
why it's called this
so for the last almost 20 years
there's one research question that i
keep coming back to
i keep circling around the following
question
how do we change people's attitudes and
behavior
with
through
and after technology
and the after part is important
what remains
once you take the technological
scaffolding away
so that's what the the meat or the
beyond meat substitute of this talk will
be
i will answer this question but for a
bounded context and for particular types
of players because i don't believe that
there's a universal approach so
throughout the talk
i'm going to keep presenting two ongoing
examples
so one example concerns the project
neocarb
which is part of a larger project that i
lead which is called speculative play
and the other pro the other example i'll
talk about concerns the 2017 edition of
the skins workshop
which runs under a different project
that i'm part of
the initiative for indigenous futures
so some background on both of these
projects starting with speculative play
speculative play is essentially a merger
of two schools of design thought
speculative and critical design
and playful media design
now in case the terms speculative and
critical design are unfamiliar they can
both be folded together under the idea
of using design rhetorically to prompt
speculation on alternative presence and
futures
and these forms of design are about
reimagining often invisible and deeply
embedded cultural assumptions
of how the world is
and proposes instead how the world could
be
my partner and collaborator
tiffen barr
he and i had the realization a few years
ago that the space that's occupied by
speculative and critical design or scd
for short
this space is intriguing it's closer to
contemporary art than mass-produced
design
and the subject matter it tends to deal
with is complex and nuanced it's it's
intellectually umami
at the same time
much of what we kept encountering in
terms of speculative and critical design
was not very playful and it was often
inaccessible in terms of access or
because of lack of interactivity
so in our work
we ask the question
can we leverage familiar playful and
digital interactions to bring a complex
social and cultural questions to life
and ideally
can we also bring these experiences to
people beyond the universities the
galleries the ivory towers
project neocup concerns a speculative
play experience that poses questions
about how we deal with religious
diversity in secular western countries
so specifically it presents a dystopian
workaround for cultural and religious
tolerance concerning muslim women who
wear nikab which is the full face cover
and this is for the purpose of getting
people to experientially grapple with
the complexities of this debate in an
embodied manner
so why would i choose to make work about
this
well in quebec which is where i live
there's legislation in place that bans
women from wearing the niqab
so the other recurring example
is the 2017 skins workshop part of the
initiative for indigenous futures which
is a project led by jason edward lewis
and in a nutshell the goal of skins is
to support indigenous folks in making a
fully fledged game
that results in indigenous people making
up spaces and taking up spaces
so in skins over three weeks workshop
participants develop digital games that
centralize and celebrate indigenous
narratives in contemporary and
futuristic settings skims is a
manifestation of indigenous futurisms
and this is a term that was coined by
the science fiction and and indigenous
nations scholar grace dylan
and it has its roots in science fiction
shekinah futurism
decolonization and of course indigenous
self-determination
skins 2017 took place in hawaii and
resulted in the game
which means a new world
is about a kanaka maori or indigenous
hawaiian space traveler
in a world that refuses to be captured
by the discourses and patterns of
colonization the game asks
how would hawaiians do space travel
so these projects have much in common
both concern us speculating about
different worlds and ultimately us
being able to speculate about this world
differently
so that's that's the speculation angle
but as for resonation
the project intentions for both
speculative play and indigenous futures
ultimately seek to move past speculating
and are in fact
can design resonate with us in ways that
change us
so by resonation i'm invoking the idea
of design experiences that stick with us
that echo with us
but because i'm often thinking about
attitude and behavior change
resonation also concerns
design that changes us
now i consider myself an
interdisciplinary academic itinerantly
couchsurfing between computer science
and design
so i'll do the thing that
interdisciplinary academics do
i'm going to weep together an argument
that draws on threads from various
disciplines and practices
including game design interaction design
role-playing studies and behavioral
psychology
this argument will take the form of
seven parts each brought to life with
one of the recurring examples
and seven incidentally maps precisely
onto miller's law which as you'll know
is the number of things you can
comfortably keep in mind
so let's start where game study started
with play and culture
so when i first started researching
games during my phd which i did in new
zealand i was interested in how
persuasive appeals mediated through
technology interacted with cultural
values
and basically my research question was
when you're making a persuasive game
which in my case was games persuading
people to quit smoking
does the cultural flavor of the
persuasion matter
so will a game that evokes white new
zealand culture work on indigenous new
zealanders and vice versa
and the tldr for that work is if you
want to persuade people to do something
or shift an attitude
you'll be more successful if you
reference their cultural values and
beliefs in the media whether the media
concern a game a ui
or some kind of advertising
and this is doubly important if you're
dealing with a minority community
because psychology psychology shows us
that people respond especially favorably
to persuasive appeals if they feel
they're definitively the target audience
then the era of gamification erupted the
use of game elements in non-game
contexts like banking and
contributing to user communities habit
building becoming a better runner
and this is all with the hope of using
the motivational power of games to make
people do things
but then a few years into you know that
trajectory the rise and fall of
gamification as it were
with some exceptions it became apparent
that there was a kind of design ceiling
or lack of lack of imagination for one
gamified systems looked like
what they felt like what they played
like
and almost all of those systems used the
same design formula of points badges and
leaderboards
and most of them were about competition
and achievement
and my phd research findings suddenly
found new and different echoes
gamified systems concerned play that's
happening
in the wild
in the world
because they're not strictly games
because they often take place in
non-place settings
the notion of any magic circle is called
into question
in the very least we should accept that
the bounding lines of any gamification
circle
are
porous
or perhaps they're translucent
or maybe they're blinking
and that at any moment we might find
ourselves
no longer inside a magic circle
so then the question becomes
does the gamification work if the circle
has blinked off or if it's translucent
maybe
but in those cases you still need to
remember that the rule set is still
there
the one that never really goes away
and the rules and i'm talking about here
is
our cultural rule set
so culture is the software of the mind
um this is like a phrase famously coined
by hofstetter the software of the mind
and part of why he chose this metaphor
is this idea that we can't turn our
cultures off our culture is always
running
so back to the idea of the magic circle
if the circle is in a state of flux
people's default fallback rules are
their cultural rules
so thesis one
culture is the fundamental set of rules
that we play by
so on to our first example now
so neocob enables audience members to
control each other's appearance without
their consent
and it's a dark riff on nikah bands that
have cropped up the world over
but in the fictional world of neocon
because remember this is a it's a
speculative technology so instead of
there being neca bands in this world
this technology enables censoring and in
a sense uncensoring of people who are
masked so you can force a face onto
someone who's wearing niqab
but who didn't want to be seen
and the rhetorical intention here is not
to convince people that this is an
effective product or even a good idea
it's to make people reflect on their
community and society's stance
towards visible religious difference
and our own boundaries regarding
tolerance and individual rights
so neocob is
a speculative critical design an scd
and scds can be understood as a form of
persuasive design
because they often invite audience
members to imagine the world differently
but a core difference between
scds and say a serious game or a
persuasive game
is that scds might just be an object or
a number of related objects that you can
interact with
so in the case of our project our
objects were two apps and an on-screen
projection and collectively
these objects
pointed to they evoked a fictional world
but that world wasn't clearly bounded as
is often the case with games right like
you're playing a game and
it firmly believes that that game exists
somehow between the screen and your
console
and it feels bounded
but that's not the case for a cds
so best practice design advice for scds
tells us that there's a sweet spot for
contextualizing or situating an
experience which is somewhere between
familiar and unfamiliar
so when it's too familiar
and the concept is understandable
it's boring
but if it's too unfamiliar
the concept might be interesting but
it's irrelevant
but that space in between
it's familiar enough that we sort of
relate to it but it's unfamiliar enough
that we can't operate on autopilot and
we bother to sit up and pay attention
so in this way
scds like gamification
rely on our cultural rule sets to be
understood
because that in between space is a
dotted magic circle
so anyone who experiences neocab in a
quebec context for instance will most
likely be reminded of the very real
niqab band that applies to quebec but
not to the rest of canada
they will likely think of snapchat
filters they'll think of twitter
and they'll think about canadian
politeness rules
for what you're supposed to do when
you're faced with other people
all right so moving on now part two
bleed and familiarity
in 2010 i was teaching a game design
class in copenhagen
i told the students that after the break
we would play a larp a live action role
play and that we would play this larp
together
and they piled out of the classroom the
10 minutes of the break went by and then
from the class of 45 students or so
only about 10 of those students came
back and the others had run away on
hearing that they would have to lock
which in retrospect i should have
predicted because in most people's
imaginations
larp
looks like this
towards larp have shifted a lot in the
last decade or so
nordic larp in particular has attained a
status which is somewhere between games
experimental theater and performance art
we should also acknowledge that there is
crossover between the role-playing
studies community and the game studies
community via folks like jacob steinross
and marcus
montolo and one phenomenon that larkers
are familiar with is bleed when there is
a carryover of experience either from
player to larp character or from larp
character to player
and the classic example of bleed and
larp is a larp crush or emotional bleed
when the feelings characters have for
each other in-game i.e characters who
are lovers so bella and edward from
twilight for instance so when those
feelings carry over to players feelings
for each other out of game
so kristen stewart and robert patterson
ended up together in real life for a few
years
so about this metaphor
bleed for me evokes well blood first of
all obviously
but in my experience it's actually
metaphors for ink which is another
substance that famously bleeds
that do the best job for explaining the
notion of bleed
so consider what happens when you hold
an inky pan down on a piece of paper
the ink flows out from the pen becoming
increasingly concentrated under the tip
of the pen
and if your piece of paper isn't
cardboard you're probably going to
encounter pink bleed
and the wisdom of
www.fountainpinlove.com tells
us bleeding occurs when ink soaks
through a piece of paper onto the other
side ink might soak through onto the
next piece of paper or even the surface
that you're writing on
so
why i actually i like this is it's
it's one of the best accidental
explanations i've come across that sort
of experientially describes what's going
on with larp bleed
so
your piece of paper is the magic circle
or rather the thickness of the piece of
paper is the magic circle
and bleed is the carryover the crossover
to the other side
so
if
if that's uh the thickness if it's a
thin piece of paper
then bleed happens
if it's thick
bleed won't happen
so back to larp now
lockers talk about bleed in which is
when players transpose aspects of their
lived experience onto their characters
inside the magic circle of play
and there's also bleed out which is when
you drag aspects of your character back
into your regular lived reality
so some lockers like to play in a way
that plays up bleed while other lockers
try to play in a way that plays down
bleed
and the rule of thumb here is that the
more a character is like how you are in
real life
the more you are likely to experience
bleed
bleed isn't strictly under players
control though but lockers will talk
about steering their character in ways
that could lead to bleed
so that brings us to thesis two players
can be steered towards bleed
all right let's flesh this out more with
the neocarb example so with neocon if
after experiencing it people never again
think about niqab and controlling
people's appearances
that for me
is a massive design fail
so with scds we do want bleed and
specifically we want bleed out because
the scd needs to risen
with people's experiences in the real
world after play
and part of this we have already because
recall that design best practice for
scds is that they should seem somewhat
familiar you know enabling that there is
some degree of overlap between your
fictional world self and your real world
self
so in neocob the character that you play
is basically just yourself but armed
with a slightly strange technology
the first interface that we had for
selecting replacement bodies which you
can just make out and you can just make
out in the image
uh yeah there's sort of two two hazy
figures in the background there
so the first interface that we had for
selecting that replacement body was
inspired by
census forms
and we had solid intellectualized
reasons for why
census forms were a really great way to
kind of succinctly
sum up
the categories that we place on people
when we're trying to understand their
identity
but people couldn't relate to the idea
of census forms
um during play
it was just
it was totally fine to them it was too
clunky and
there was nothing natural about it
so the redesigned version co-opted the
tinder swipe which is a familiar
physical gesture it's an efficient
gesture and it's also a highly
culturally resonant one
thus more likely to steer players
towards bleed
so in retrospect it's easy to over
design into a more unfamiliar fictional
world and subtly harder to evoke the
present world
so if we want more bleed
we should focus on remixing experiences
that are already familiar because this
means that they're more likely to
resonate for us
in english there's a proverb that
captures this idea really nicely
there's nothing new under the sun
which is in fact a translation of the
earlier latin
niels of
novum
and this itself is a translation of the
original hebrew
which i'm going to go ahead and try and
read and call hadas
so the fact that this proverb is still
in circulation and still resonates for
us thousands of years later
tells us everything
all right on to part three play design
and resonance
within game studies we're comfortable
with the idea that a game in a sense
doesn't exist unless it's being played
and
the game experiences are co-constructed
between designers rules and play
affordances and players
with the players exerting choice in
action to give the play affordances
meaning
in the moment
so larpers do this too but in general
they have quite a lot of freedom when it
comes to choice and action they have a
lot more or authorial agency
larpers are shaping articulating and
designing their characters as they go as
well as co-constructing game worlds and
histories
herbert simon gave the world a
definition of design which is
it's abstract enough to apply to many
different types of design
so as he said to design is to devise
forces of action aimed at changing
existing existing situations into
preferred ones
so libras use the constraints of their
character roles to steer game worlds in
ways that they want
so in this way
larp players lockers are actually doing
a lot of real-time live design
and for many lockers the easiest way to
create and maintain a consistent
believable and compelling character is
to write what you know or play what you
know or design what you know
so on screen is the uh the character
cards for a lot called dole
run um by artist and
also happens to be my friend francis
patrick brady
when he runs his larp online you have
about one minute to come up with a
character story
and your character cards are just
randomly assigned to you
so if i'm needing to come up with a
character
for hyper bureaucratic bio actor under
time pressure in just one minute
i'm going to resort to my lived
experiences of bureaucracy of actors
and the people around me when i shop at
the health food store who for some
reason i'm convinced they know way more
about organic foods than i do
and in fact larpers are drawing on their
lived experience all the time
this also explains why a lot of lockers
end up playing the same type of
characters time and time again they're
working with what they know
and this brings us to thesis three we
design well what we know well
and a logical a logical conclusion of
this is that it is harder to believably
convey stories that are far away from
your own
so let's look at an example
indigenous and racialized people the
world over are often largely ignored
when it comes to mainstream video games
so on screen is a level of barbie
supermodel for the sega genesis set in
honolulu hawaii
notice how there are no indigenous
people anywhere to be seen here
so that's one case
they're simply not there effectively
they've been erased
and the other typical case is that
they're offensively or problematically
stereotyped so here we have the the
noble savage stereotype we have shooting
beaver from mad dog 2
who is an ally of the player but then
immediately helps the player kill some
indians
and the rationale for the lack of
representation used to be economic
that racialized folks simply weren't a
powerful enough consumer base to bother
focusing on
but the game playing and buying
demographics
have changed a lot since the early 1980s
when the home console game market was
first taking off
researchers show us that there's still a
discrepancy between who's buying games
and who gets positively represented of
them
and the tldr is white folks are still
significantly over represented
and this is how what we know well
becomes part of the problem the games
industry still doesn't know racialized
folks well enough it's unlikely
indigenous americans would have come up
with narratives like that of mad dog too
racialized folks by and large aren't
telling their own stories within
mainstream games instead they have their
stories told by others
but bringing this back to larp
our lived human experiences are a
powerful design tool
and for the games industry to
respectfully and appropriately know a
wider slice of the human experience that
needs to be more diverse and more
reflective of the player audience
the skins workshop exists in no small
part to facilitate indigenous folks in
obtaining technical game making skills
such that there's a higher chance that
they can eventually enter the game
industry
should they be so inclined
and the games industry desperately needs
designers who can confidently represent
their own communities and
positionalities
so what we know
will get larger
and games will do a better job of
resonantly conveying the breadth of the
human experience
all right so on to four design and the
magic circle
when we talk about game design we end up
talking a lot about players and the
player experience
we talk less about how establishing game
worlds and game rules requires a special
mindset
to design a fictional world is to build
it up
whether with lego code
or your imagination
to design a fictional world we have to
build foundations for a magic circle
if we're not explicitly playing the game
ourselves we imagine ourselves or others
playing within the constraints that
we've established
okay so to imagine the game being played
this is a rehearsal of play
and a rehearsal of play
is a form of play so in a sense when we
design
we do so from inside the magic circle
so thesis four
we design inside the magic circle
skins is founded on the idea of
indigenous futurisms so representing
futures in which indigenous people are
not just present
but thriving
and what's key to its philosophy is that
these futures are self-determined
and self-narrated
so when brainstorming narrative concepts
in the 2017 edition of skins
one of our workshop participants
once
he contributed his idea kanaka maoli
indigenous hawaiians
in outer space
and the immediate reaction in the room
was laughter
but then once that locker died down
mikey
another participant asked but why is
that funny why shouldn't we be in outer
space
and of all the myriad ideas that were
brainstormed the initially outlandish
idea of kanakamali in outer space
ended up being the core idea of
when we design we explore
chart
rehearse and articulate courses of
action
the designers of hai
established an internally consistent
world
in which indigenous hawaiians could be
in space and respectfully in a way that
honors their culture
this doesn't yet mean that indigenous
hawaiians are now literally in outer
space
but the fact of exploring charting
rehearsing and articulating stories
involving indigenous hawaiians in space
even once
means that the stories that are similar
to this the thinking that is similar to
this becomes within reach
okay so on to part five
design and realization
in interaction design we think about
interactivity as conversations
so if my like icon
is this size
what do users understand about what i
want or expect them to do
what if it is
this size
so game design is essentially the same
when i play a game
i'm having a slow conversation with its
designer
mediated through its rule system and its
material affordances
so every interaction i have with or
through a game
enables me to gradually add to a mental
model of a game world that hopefully
resembles the one that the designer
intended for me to form
when we play games especially for the
first time
we realize things about the game world
in the sense that and i so realized in
the sense of we make sense of it we
understand how it operates
but realize the word realize also has a
different meaning
it can mean to make something real
so the choices that game designers make
literally shape how we can act and
behave as players
game designer world's design is about
choreographing or inviting specific
types of play
and that play can be a rehearsal for a
way of being in the world
so thesis five
to design
is to realize
now when there isn't much media about
your community out there whatever there
is takes on an outsized impact and
responsibility
it's notable that every edition of the
skins workshop that i've ever been
involved in the participants have always
collectively agreed
that what they want to represent about
their culture is what they consider to
be what is best and most valuable about
their culture
in here outhou
participants had a vision of ethical
space travel that does not echo the
strategies of colonization
so the design decisions that they took
from the mechanics of using the hawaiian
pupoy nut as a way to purify water
to making players focus and copy the
moves of a sacred dance
to the narrative strategies of having
the main character only ever visit and
never take over the land they find
to the featuring of the kumulipo and the
games audio soundtrack the hawaiian
origin myth for the world
these all invite us to play in
particular ways to enact particular
courses of action
and to make real hawaiian ways of being
and seeing the world
so stated a different way
the design choices of her au hou
make it impossible to play as a
colonizer
the design choices of her au hong
collectively work to realize to make
real
decolonial space exploration
play becomes an externalized
manifestation of what the designer had
in mind
play is a materialized
realized resonation of the designer's
speculation
the speculated worlds that we embed into
games and playful media carry
significance for ourselves
as we meditate on ways of being in those
worlds but also for future players whose
play continues to realize those worlds
okay so on to part six
so in game design normally we love
immersion so the more immersive the
better
as far as games go
game designers are especially big fans
of the late
mihai shiks and mihai's flow theory
in the words of eminem who i'm sure most
of you don't even know who that is
anymore there's the design imperative to
to lose yourself
but immersion and critical reflection
are literally at odds with one another
pedagogical research argues that in
order to be thinking about something
critically
you need to be able to think about it at
arm's length and this is why we have
that expression critical distance
augusto boyle makes the same kind of
argument but in the context of theater
and theatrical immersion and
specifically um in the context of
aristotelian theatrical immersion
and his reasoning goes like this
as spectators when we see experiences of
for instance injustice or oppression
played out in a theater context by
actors
though we might feel very moved in the
moment of watching
the fact that we're not directly
involved means that we absolve ourselves
of any responsibility
or need to do anything
so you can transpose the exact same
argument onto other forms of immersive
media so say you've watched
blood diamond
as i did
and you're appalled at what you learned
about diamond mining and the diamond
trade as i was
but then
you do squarely nothing with that
newfound knowledge
which is what i did
now
is that because i'm a bad person
well
maybe
but bowal has a kinder interpretation of
my response
his claim is that the boundaries of
fiction
mean that we don't feel that we need to
be accountable responsible or responsive
to what we've experienced
and paul's solution
which is balian theater
is to have his spectators watch plays
and to then invite them to replay scenes
where they take on the roles played by
actors
so in bow alien theater the fourth wall
is always made very very obvious the
sets are pretty bare bones
plot lines aren't set in stone
conversations take place between plays
and replays and during these
conversations um
the actors the the participants people
in the audience everyone is discussing
about what could have been done
and the regular breaking of immersion
here this is what makes room for
critical reflection
immersion is still part of the
experience but it's interspersed with
being outside of immersion which is
ultimately when reflection happens
so if there is any magic circle in bali
and theater it most definitely has a
dotted line
so that gets us to thesis six
immersion and reflection need to be
choreographed
conscientiously
so in larp as well as simulation
training games that get used in the
workplace
it's very common to have a debrief after
play where players discuss how the larp
went
and will talk about the experiences of
their characters
and this conversation serves as a
critically reflective stitching together
of what happened inside the play
experience or the magic circle
and what we believe when we're no longer
in our play character
and this runs counter to the fantasy of
games and play just like magically
changing who we are and what we believe
but as theories of behavior change such
as the trans-theoretical models suggest
change comes more easily when we
consciously contemplate it
so on to our example
games are by and large
excellent at explaining their own worlds
through narrative devices and mechanics
perhaps in the game world your character
wakes up and reports that he
very conveniently has amnesia
and you have to run around bothering
everyone until you learn who your
character is
which by the way is exactly the plot of
disco elysium
or perhaps you find your your notebook
reminding you of what you need to do
so unlike games
critical and speculative designs so
their cds they usually don't concern
fully bounded separated worlds
um so they they concern
one or more multiple objects that that
hints at a world
so for instance the main object of the
neocarb world is simply an app that you
deploy on someone else
but it doesn't
ever give you a full explanation of the
world that surrounds it
so if you were to encounter
this neocon app
not knowing that it was an scd
it wouldn't make much sense and
quite possibly you would find it very
offensive
um so this kind this this sort of lack
of an explanation of the surrounding
world it's sort of a bug of scd but from
another perspective it's a feature right
because it creates an opportunity and
need
for the outside of immersion reflection
to happen
so neocob is
always intended to be accompanied by
some kind of a debrief after
participants have experienced it to to
fill in missing details of what that
neocon world
is about
but also to engage with participants
about what they did and why
and how it connects to their day-to-day
selves
all right so now we're at part seven
resignation and reminders
you know that experience where you go
away on holiday
you're in say kyoto and everything seems
fresh and possible and the world feels
full of hope
and you tell yourself
i feel amazing and when i get home
things are going to be
amazing and then you get home and things
aren't amazing
and the reason is
you're not on holiday anymore
so theories of behavior change have been
telling us for decades now that our
environment is a crucial factor in
predicting the success of behavior
change
we're creatures of habit we use our
environmental cues heavily to cure
as to what to do and how to behave so if
you want to stop smoke smoking
form new habits to do instead of smoking
ideally in an environment that is
somehow different
so designers who dabble in unpleasant
design and hostile architecture they
know this principle very well
we use the affordances in our
environment heavily
so they change the environment to shape
our behaviors
so look look at this thing i don't even
know what to call it it's like half of a
bench and it's sort of not the useful
half either so i can't sit here and i
can't lie down here best case i can i
can lean here temporarily
but if we were to frame this idea
positively
cues and reminders of the behavioral
change you want to make
can be helpful and motivational for
maintaining change so
this might be an elastic band on your
wrist that you snap when you find
yourself slouching and you're trying to
maintain good posture
it might be a message from your best
friend
who posted who posted you something on
run keeper about how impressively fast
you ran
it might be a vibration on your wrist
telling you that you've been sitting in
the same spot for three hours straight
so that gets us to thesis seven
maintaining change is easier with
reminders
so play experiences and ones that invite
us to change our attitudes or behaviors
are particular
because unlike productivity or lifestyle
apps so apps like run keepers say
they happen within a magic circle right
it's bowel's problem with immersive
experiences all over again
there's a kind of conceptual boundary
from the here and now
so even if we accept that that circle is
porous
it's a type of kyoto holiday
and we can't take our play situation
with us when we stop playing that would
be akin to living your life as a
non-stop larp
but we can learn from behavioral
psychology
and think about whether we can
implicitly or explicitly design for
anchors that reach from inside to
outside that magic circle
and these anchors are basically like
reminders or resonations
so
what could constitute an anchor
an anchor might be a playing card from a
game session it might be a physical
location where you were playing
a muscle memory action that you've now
just internalized
notes that you made to help you while
you were playing
maybe a journal entry that you made
after playing
or a circle of people who you've played
with and designed with and who's who you
stay in touch with
so prior to the skins workshop in 2017
almost none of our participants had
crossed parts before despite all of them
being individually interested in
indigenous identity and game making
but the 2017 cohort which adopted the
collective moniker
still remain in contact today via a
facebook page
they share information on current game
dev and media so
yeah like we even had
some skins mentors who came back to the
next edition of the workshop because
they wanted to be able to completely
organize skins workshops on their own
so
these folks they spent just three weeks
with us and developed only one game with
us
but the cumulative resonance of skins
reached way further than that
we couldn't have predicted the community
bonds that would develop and we can't
take credit for their community
maintenance either that was completely
them that was their own volition and
they did it all with
very little in the way of material
resources from us
but that bond that support network it
wasn't fictional or imaginary or inside
any kind of magic circle it's very much
real it exists very much in this world
so at the start of this talk i shared
the question that keeps shaping and
motivating my work
how do we change people's
attitudes and behavior with through and
after technology
and i said i'd develop an answer in
seven parts so let's finally bring those
parts together
so number one
culture is the fundamental set of rules
that we play by
two
players can be steered towards bleed
three
we design well what we know well
four
we design inside the magic circle
five
to design is to realize
sex
immersion and reflection need to be
choreographed conscientiously
and seven maintaining change is easier
with reminders
so across these seven parts
there's two meta themes which both
involve blurring
the first is
that games and play blur into live
experience in all kinds of ways so we
shouldn't approach them as
boxed off from one another it's also not
a failing if play experiences are
reinforced by outside of play
experiences because research shows us
that this is more likely to lead to
change
and the second sort of meta
meta learning is that play and design
can blur into each other
we use the magic circle as a construct
for understanding play
but there's a logic to using it to
understand design as well
so in closing
if you want to support speculation
resonation and situations involving play
embrace the spaces
of blair
so you talked about the blood diamond
example and having a game would
strengthen their understanding i've
created a game about the awareness of
gerrymandering
but i'm not sure how i can do more than
that for example asking people to
campaign against
gerrymandering what are your thoughts
about it
so that's okay this is an interesting
question
so i like first start it's it's really
great that you you were you felt
compelled to go ahead and make a game
about this
the um the blood diamond example sort of
fit
into a larger framework of bowels idea
of theater of the oppressed
where his basic claim is if you really
want to change
people's minds you need to directly
involve them into the action
so
uh
one way in which you can
make that um
immediately more possible with games is
that you create instead of making a game
that is like a single player game with a
very clear procedural rhetoric right
this would be uh sort of
ian bogo style
uh persuasive game design from the early
2000s instead i would say what you
should do
is create a multiplayer game
where you have game rules um where you
know the game logics
speak to you know concepts around
gerrymandering sort of inequalities that
this can foster
so that is sort of embodied within the
game structural level but because
because
the drama is now being
enacted between people
between
people who exist in the world and have
actual ideologies that they're driven by
then immediately the game is operating
at a higher level
all right so that's um that's one way in
which you can immediately immediately
get people more involved is think about
is there a way that i can make my game
multiplayer
and if you can't if you can't do that
then uh
i would say one thing that you can
always always always do
is make sure that you get
players of your games
to have conversations about their play
experience after so whether that's with
other people who've played the game
whether that's with you as the designer
the maker the researcher but um just
having some sort of
outside of immersion moment where you
get the players to
to basically commence to
like storm the memory of that game
um
in their heads
as people in this material world okay
that's how you're much more likely to
to make them to activate them to make
them care more
all right
uh
okay so i have
another question here
so
it says
how important is immersion for games to
succeed
and do we need to and if we need to
break immersion does it make the game
less successful and lead to less people
to experience your scd
this is um this is kind of a contentious
one
because just because like particularly
within
game design circles we've been for so
long we've been fed this line that the
more immersive a game is the better it
is
like we've been told that that's what
you want
that's the experience that we should be
driving for is that people are sort of
at one with the game world
and i think at this point in time we've
moved on from the idea that
it's automatically better to be
deeply immersed in the world
um
for the reason that
now we acknowledge that
when people play games they're sort of
uh
they're sort of connecting with the game
at different levels like it's not the
case that just because i'm playing the
game i can't also be paying attention to
the fact that my kettle is boiling right
when like we've now moved on a lot from
20 years ago when just there was the
idea that immersion meant like
total focus and this is actually kind of
a
sort of confusion that stems from early
vr research that was done in the 1990s
so that idea of immersion was really
sort of mixed with the idea of presence
and if you're thinking of about presence
in a vr context it's literally it's
about being cut off
from the outside
um so all right uh this is a bit of a
digression how important is immersion
for games to succeed
i
i think actually now
um
what is
more important than immersion
would be that people go into experiences
open-minded
and willing to commit to the fiction of
the game
right because you can't actually
convince yourself to be immersed more
right because you you can role play
something very simply you can role play
something
without a script right if you're just
chewing the fat with your friends you
can role play something you can bring a
scenario to life so
yes immersion helps but it's not the
be-all and end-all and i think we are at
the point now where we should recognize
that
as individuals who consume media who
play games
we bring a lot of agency to how we
interpret our play experiences
and
yep
really like um
so
okay this this also makes me want to
talk a little bit about
everything that's wrong with old school
serious games
all right uh we've had problems getting
our sound to go through in the world i
want to thank rila for brilliant talk
that has many great questions from many
of us okay
hey thank you all so much um
i'm sorry that i couldn't see you i
think i would have gotten a huge kick
out of seeing you all but thank you so
much